one of the first jobs I ever had which
was before lovely and amazing which was
a job but it was a big movie it was a
big movie called the ghost in the
darkness and it was a big Hollywood
thing I was Val Kilmer's wife but I got
eaten by a lion very early on in the
procedure but I remember my first day on
that job and there was this huge kind of
I was in Africa and I it was all about
man-eating lions in Africa and I'd
arrived and I had walked out of this set
full of you know thousands of extras and
I had to be standing there with my sort
of baby and having come to meet val
kilmer and it was quite overwhelming and
I remember the director coming up to me
and saying um after my first take and
saying oh that was really that was
really you know good you did really well
well done you've got a slightly sleepy
left eye so could you just try and open
it a little bit and I was like oh yeah
yeah sure definitely cause then
absolutely you know really well yeah
completely I don't yeah I do I know I do
have slightly where those that and so he
went off and I was left there thinking
wait I don't know how to open my sleepy
up point like that I don't know how to
do that so I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
maybe close the other eye a little bit
to make way and then they would say so I
know that you know rolling rolling
turnover and all these thousands of
extras and I was like all I was doing
was trying to make my eyes the same size
and who is one of them too and if you
look at this you look at the shot and
it's just you know it's like what is
that woman doing but I think I love it
really hang on from that that you just
sort of don't pay attention to [ __ ] like
that like just either don't pay
attention to it or say you know oh
that's work you know I that you have to
kind of you have to sort of not be too
obliging and and people completely are
able to handle it you know a you just
have to sort of if something don't how
ever shot you are however nice you are
don't prioritize pleasing people over
what happens between action and quality
you know you just have to be in that
moment in that world and not thinking
about anything to do with your tiny eyes
or your even a plan or any of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]